[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this week on
you made it weird is the incredible
Chelsea Handler here's a little taste I
wasn't ever a people pleaser and I never
have been because I also just can't be
inauthentic I can't be fake even if I
don't like someone and I'm talking to
them everyone will know that I don't
like that person even if I'm smiling and
trying to pretend I cannot you seem like
that kind of person you actually remind
me a lot of my best friend in college
her name's Jamie and she was that way
and I just couldn't be more tickled
hanging out with her because if she
didn't like somebody was like right on
her face yes but it's very it's because
I have no I have no Bluff like yeah so
it's also inconvenient you know what I
mean for people and their feelings holy
cow uh this is Chelsea Handler I I've
been uh wanting to have Chelsea on the
podcast for a very very long time and
I'm very very excited that she's here
and I'm excited for you guys to hear it
if you guys listen to the we made it
weirds which are me and Val every Friday
you know that I was quite taken with
Chelsea we were left thing about just
how impressed I was with her she's funny
she's sharp she's interesting and you're
going to hear all of that right now
check out her Netflix special it's
called revolution
revolution it's on uh Netflix which is a
website and an app wet net netflix.com
check it out also if you'd like to see
me do stand up I just added a whole new
bunch of tour dates and they are all at
petehomes.com Atlanta Charlotte
Washington DC Vancouver Grand Rapids San
Diego New Orleans Dallas Houston
Milwaukee Madison Royal Oak Michigan oh
well oh yeah that's uh Gilda's laugh
fest in Grand Rapids or near Grand
Rapids I guess Minneapolis New York New
York
and uh Ridgefield Connecticut so those
are all at petehomes.com hope you can
come out uh this episode is brought To
Us by what I'm currently wearing right
now this is absolutely a life-changing
piece of technology this is my Apollo
neuro for those of you listening you
can't see it but it basically looks like
a a wristwatch that I basically
basically heavy on the basically is in
the intro have it on the inside of my
wrist but it's not a it's not a watch
it's uh what is it it's a piece of
wearable tech you guys hear about this
wearable tech going around Apollo neuro
is basically like a wearable hug for
your nervous system what does that mean
means currently right now I have it on a
setting called rebuild and recover and
it's delivering directly into my nervous
system in a language that my nervous
system can understand
gentle almost sub-perceptual vibration
meaning it's not something I notice it's
just kind of running throughout my day
but it's delivering vibrations that are
received to my system as a message in
this case to rebuild to recover after a
long day and a lot of physical activity
it's been shown to help with recovery
but that's not it it also helps with
energy G and waking up it helps with
being social and open which is a great
setting for Creative work in fact when
I'm wearing it which is every episode on
this podcast I'm rocking it on social
and open clear and focused has been
shown clinically to help people with uh
procrastination focused uh all the
symptoms of ADHD that we're all familiar
with meditation and mindfulness it helps
you get deeper in your meditation
practice just by lulling you into a more
calm State basically giving your body
The Sensation that it's being held which
is incredible at night I put it on relax
and unwind and that's what I have it on
when I'm watching a TV or reading a book
at the end of the night helps me fall
asleep faster and also the sleep and
renew if all this thing did was help me
fall asleep and stay asleep with no you
know not a pharmaceutical no drug
nothing like that it would be worth it
I'd already be singing its Praises but
it does all of those things my favorite
thing about it is if I get up in the
middle of night use the bathroom or
something come back in bed my brain
starts going like okay I'm we got
tomorrow what are we going to do it
starts worrying I hit the two buttons on
this no need to go on your phone or
anything it reruns the last program
sleep and renew runs again and it gently
lulls me back to sleep sometimes I
describe it like if you're if someone's
patting you like this like a rhythm
and then they slow down the Rhythm
that physical touch can tell your
nervous system it's safe it is not in
danger it's okay to go to sleep or it's
okay to meditate or in the in the
opposite it can get your heartbeat going
the energy and wake up setting is like
drinking an espresso but you don't have
to get any chemical nothing like
caffeine in your system and you'll still
get that jolt of energy so it is a
wearable that helps you recover from
stress helps you use touch therapy to
feel safe and in control
I wear it on my wrist you can also wear
it on your ankle soothing vibrations
that train your nervous system to
recover and rebalance after stress I
always say this but it is not woo-woo
it's not sold in crystal shops it was
designed by a neuroscientist and a
board-certified psychiatrist who have
been studying the impacts of chronic
stress in humans for nearly 15 years and
Apollo's effect on stress sleep
cognitive performance and Recovery have
been proven in multiple clinical trials
and real world studies and there's
always more coming in I'm in touch with
these guys and they're always sending me
new studies more data that shows that
this works in fact on the road it's
really nice I meet more and more weirdos
that are wearing them and they say thank
you for introducing me to the Apollo
that is why I'm so glad to be working
with them and why grateful to have them
to bring us this episode you can give it
a try or give it as a gift we've given
away I think at least 10 of them as a
gift so go to apollonuro.com weird
you'll get 10 off and it means so much
it shows support of this podcast Apo llo
n-e-u-r-o.com
slash weird 10 off and feel a little bit
more in control a little bit safer a
little bit more relaxed more energized
whatever you needed to do it's like the
finding the fuse box to your body so
give it a try and in the meantime hope
to see you on the road go to petomes.com
check out Chelsea's uh latest special
Revolution on Netflix and enjoy this
wonderful chat
get into it
viral video oh no
it is is that fun
is it fun to just I mean I always say to
my to Val my wife I was like I would
have loved to been like a big sexy
brother a big breasted big breasted
broad yeah yeah because I dated a big
Buxom lady it was very sexy like
wherever we went she got kind of like
comments and and I was like that looks
so it looks like
comedy became a person it was like the
look at me body yeah like a Betty boot
body a Betty Boop a vivacious body a
curvaceous sort of I don't all bodies
are beautiful obviously but some are
more rare so this was like just kind of
like seeing like a puma would you turn
this off Katie just like seeing
something so and and I used to be doing
like hot air blowing on you while you're
talking to somebody with I have enough
blowing at me from this direction two
camera
oh my God hi you guys I didn't even see
you guys standing there two yeah there
are three thin men oh exciting cyclopsis
I love a cyclops I was gonna say black
Cyclops is because they are colored
black but I didn't want to get in
trouble yeah yeah you can't say you can
say it you could I could say props
because I would actually be talking
about a black Cyclops that's the
difference because you're are you going
smarter smarter wait what were you going
to say
like I thought maybe you were losing
your mind
um you know I am I am losing my mind
thank you I am senile and I mean I've
already forgotten more than most people
will ever experience that's right and I
don't I mean I meet people and I'm just
like Hello nice to meet you and then I
oh and then they're like we've met like
four or five times and I'm like exactly
that's why I said nice to see you that's
what I say now anyone even if it's the
first meeting you just say nice to see
you even though that sounds stupid I
think I met you IRL correct me if I'm
wrong I'm ready to be embarrassed in
Montreal because I think I would have
remembered this past month yeah I know
and we we're Comics so we went right
into it and that felt totally organic
organic yeah am I pitching a series back
it up are you at air one right now yep
okay well get out the only place you can
go
absolutely raw cashews truly raw most
raw cash users team Chelsea don't act
like you don't tell you that don't act
like you didn't like that too when you
asked me to do your podcast and I looked
at my calendar today it's a podcast yeah
I don't know what this is but I looked
at my calendar today to see what was up
right so I was coming over here I go I
bet Pete Holmes lives exactly where you
live is that right exactly can I ask do
you live near here because I went on a
hike once and I thought I saw you no I
hate hiking I don't like snakes it
wasn't that kind of hike it was like I
don't like hikes
what else you got
it was a hill it was just a hill it was
like a hilly area I like to ski down
Hills but I wouldn't be walking up one
that's where we're different because I'm
very tall very tall for a lady for a
lady what I'm saying I'll get canceled
for that why are you I have a certain
understanding of how tall ladies are not
to mention ladies why are you even
talking about hide Pete keep our height
out your mouth Yes I said yo this is
going wow yeah all people all different
questions for you are you religious I'm
yeah it's about to get annoying just
adjacent I'm not religious at all
sleeping in that Sunday if that's what
you mean okay because well because when
Taylor Tomlinson when she brought you up
or when you gave her her presented her
with her award this summer in Montreal
yes that's right I was presenting Amy
with her award and you were presenting
Taylor yeah and I felt like there was
some sort of religious connection there
was the two of you and I think that's
why they picked me because and when it
when Taylor was in the newspaper
the New York Times the post I don't know
what the journal who knows right okay
okay uh linings for bird cages the Wall
Street journals
big media I just don't remember which
one it is is what I'm joking I think it
was the time okay I think it was I think
I know exactly the article and I think
it was the New York Times they wrote a
really nice review uh about her stand-up
right maybe but there's also been just
like profiles about her her
religiousness and I've often because of
this podcast and because of the first
time she came on we talked at length
about her growing up sort of
fundamentalist that I was called into
common for that and because that
Association has been made that I'm
I don't know what I am but acolyte I'm
an acolyte I'm like a like a festering
sort of virus that sees who isn't I mean
there are a lot of viruses going around
and people's viral loads are way up it's
true and I just yeah there's something
to be done with loads but we're gonna
leave it alone so you're not religious
I'm spiritual okay would I I mean are
you I'm spiritual too are you spiritual
like if I was like really yeah
you could be zero because that's how I
would grow up I would grow up thinking
that if you said Duty and Kaka that you
couldn't love or have some sort of
understanding of a perspective of the
universe oh okay you understand yeah so
the fact that I'm religious would be
confusing to young people so that's kind
of what I was riffing on oh I see okay
copy that but we always talk about that
so we're going to get into your Mormon
in your judios okay great but you're
you're not religious you're spiritual I
would say I'm spiritual yeah that's
probably a spiritual as I well no I mean
I get more and more as I get all older I
understand it I get I have a better
grasp on like Vibes and energy and like
you know being like decent and decency
sorry it Chelsea you just you look like
a sleuth in a in a norm do you want me
to put a hat on or a bag over my huge
sun hat I hold this in front of my face
would you wear a floppy Sun Hatter
perhaps that is a great sweater
should I be wearing sunblock in this
room do you have any you mean your
foundation just doesn't have like an SPF
12 in it it probably does but I'm not
sure that I put foundation on today I
would do it down the way you do the way
you just had it is coming from America
should I put my sunglasses on oh my God
you guys look kind of cool I want to
just be accommodating I mean I'm not
really concerned with how I look so
don't worry okay is it not in your eyes
no well it is now oh
you look like Cindy Crawford in like a
80s Pepsi commercial oh you know what
like remember when Venetian blinds yeah
it just went right to your heart didn't
you yeah that did that right warmed me
up yes are you jking right now because
nothing was no I think that's a big
compliment and I will take it yes yeah
but also in the 80s to extend the ref
Venetian blinds and light coming through
them was like like Richard Gere looking
at a window Venetian blinds on his face
yeah we couldn't get enough of that
people still seem to have Venetian
blinds in in special situations
and they should be recalled
media
is just like they're right here this is
wrong they're happening right now as
we're talking so you're not the only
person that hasn't gotten the memo about
the 80s we got to get rid of them you
actually have gotten the memo and you
still have that you know why we always
record this podcast at 11 A.M we moved
it till 3 30 for Guess Who oh my God
well no you're thoughtful in
accommodating for being here thank you
and we're thrilled great and so are the
two ladies in that house that we went
right around to Santa meet and greet no
this ain't a mean grade it's [__]
beat it this is the meet and greet right
now this is the meet and greet this is
the mean and then yeah that's what's
gonna I won't even talk to her don't
talk to Katie
she's just so nervous right now but they
were very excited and I'm very excited
that you're here I love that yeah why
wouldn't you yeah what
let me tell you a couple you did a great
job I thought we both did a great job if
I could
in a [__] situation it was 11 A.M in
Montreal and we had to do an award show
and you had to bring up Amy Amy did
great Taylor did great Jay did great and
and I did great I'm gonna throw myself
in the mix you did do great me Persona
you didn't do great Robbie pra I can't
say this I don't have any Netflix
specials Robbie was actually disgusted
on our last phone call actually he said
because I he said something about Gerard
uh hosting the globe since I was hosting
the Critics Choice Awards yes and then
he said something I said well remember
your speech in Montreal and Robbie goes
yeah I feel like everyone remembers that
and not in a good way
I would okay that's hilarious I didn't
say that verbatim but that's the message
so you got into a rift Zone that I can't
follow you because Robbie Prada is the
comedy Booker for Netflix I love Robbie
and I know you do but you're all over
Netflix and I'm friends with Robbie but
I can't make fun of his speech at
Montreal because you know old homes he's
gonna cross his desk uh and he smashes
it like a whack-a-mole because I ripped
on a podcast oh yeah well put it on me
put it on me Robbie it's on me I'll
email them when we leave here and say
make sure you don't listen to this
episode of Pete Holmes's podcast maybe
that thing Chels what's in what are you
that's better like like we're lighting
you to be a villain in the movie well we
don't need that I'm already a big
villain
you can I ask were you always this is
our first question are you excited no
we could be you seem excited I'm excited
that you just did that perfect delivery
of now
perfect what if you had been like yeah
that would have been so disappointing
well not if I was really feeling that
way that's true that would be cute I
guess this is for you if you want it is
it a popper it's a popper I know you
like drugs so what is it it's magic mine
it's just you have a water there and
that's magic mine it's got a little
matcha in it and it helps you think I
just had one I love it Shake It Up first
there's steps
and then just shoot it is that how you
take a sip of something
no you shoot it okay this is if I said
I'd go like this this is a shoot that
was mouth what you just did was
mouthwash
you're all over the mimes it's good
you're gonna love how you feel in about
10 minutes
it sounds like I just gave you Molly
it does look like I made it with little
a funnel in my kitchen I forgot I was on
a podcast yes
I know I'm I'm not gonna do it it's new
atropics adaptogens you might need to
snort the rest of it later and matcha
and you're gonna love it and if you want
some I'll give you a case uh here's my
first question were you always did you
how quickly did you figure out that you
are at your best not being fake at all
like no not an ounce of fake and not
like placating you know what I mean like
when I started doing comedy I was like
what do you guys want to do did you
figure that out quickly
hot question hmm
it's an interesting question I think I
prefer hot question but yeah like kind
of like low energy interesting question
it's also acceptable I think I just um I
don't know really if I I'm not a people
pleaser like I like to do my job and be
professional but I don't need everyone
to like like me and I don't have that I
feel like you have to assume some people
are always going to dislike you so
anyone who does like you in the first
place is icing on the cake like I've
always looked at it that way so I never
went through a phase wait say that again
the people that are going to like you
are going to like you anyway and if
other people like you that's just a
bonus well like no there's always going
to be people that really don't like you
that's an under that's a guarantee so if
you don't have that and Everyone likes
you then you're so boring anyway so I
always just kind of was like it doesn't
matter if people don't like me just
focus on the people that do so I wasn't
ever a people pleaser and I never have
been because I also just can't be
inauthentic I can't be fake even if I
don't like someone and I'm talking to
them everyone will know that I don't
like that person even if I'm smiling and
trying to pretend I cannot you seem like
that kind of person you actually remind
me a lot of my best friend in college
her name's Jamie and she was that way
and I just couldn't be more tickled
hanging out with her because if she
didn't like somebody was like right on
her face yes but it's very it's because
I have no I have no Bluff like yeah so
it's also inconvenient you know what I
mean for people and their feelings
but not for your career it's never
gotten you in trouble has it well no I
mean sure I mean not that I can think of
but I'm sure it has gotten me in trouble
yeah because I used to like fly off the
handle about things too in in my in like
reactivity and everything and in my like
no [__] Zone but then I had to
modulate that over time learning that
that's not an effective tool when you're
no you know for forever it's childish so
you have to put a cap on it yeah so I
have to like to be a little bit more of
an adult in my life but that's the one
thing that I can't ever change is if I
you know you can tell what I'm thinking
about everybody when I'm looking at them
and that there's nothing I could do
about it right I'm trying so that's why
there wasn't a phase where you like
figured out that you could be I think
that's probably why you're so successful
and I mean this is a compliment is
you're just being yourself Yo definitely
I'm not playing any character right and
everyone knows who like all the people
that do love me like that's why they're
here you know so I know what I'm serving
up like it's it's really just me telling
my story as I go through it when I went
through one night stands and wanted to
write a book about that I wrote about
that when I went to do Ayahuasca I did a
book and a documentary about that like
I'm always telling people what I'm up to
there is no Mystique or Intrigue like
I'm not inside you know doing up to some
weird [__] um what does it feel okay
this is a leading question because I
catch myself different from you I bring
my weird stories to the stage and then
they laugh and then it's almost like
it makes me feel better I go like oh
good it's like I'm not alone people know
how I'm feeling and stuff but it doesn't
seem that doesn't seem to be your
relationship it's not like let me tell
you about this time because I feel weird
about it oh I shouldn't feel weird about
it because we're all together you're
just going like it's more confident well
it's more like my my life is always a
mess and the situations I'm in are
ridiculous always regardless of where I
I will find trouble and it's this is
that true your whole life yes everywhere
I go from the minute I was born I'm just
like a trouble magnet so or not trouble
like just Ridiculousness yeah you know
like uh uh like this summer or when
covet happened I rented this house in
Maine and I had invited a bunch of
different friends to come through for
like I rented it for like a month and my
sister my brother came up and you know
like halfway through the the trip we're
like at Kenny bunkport playing
pickleball with George Bush the George W
bush the president and I'm like I'm high
as a kite I've taken two Edibles my back
was out and I was being wheeled around
their Kenny bunkport thing on this chair
that I had to travel with because I had
like slipped a disc in my back and I am
so picturing a high back wheel it's like
a director's chair but like and being
carried and we're sitting there playing
pickleball and I told Barbara George
Bush's daughter you know I'm like [__]
I call her sister she calls me [__] and
because we've known each other and she
also colors this yeah and she calls you
[__] also and she said she was like you
have to come over and play you know
pickleball Kenny book where I was like
[__] no I can't see your father I'm
like I can't do that like I won't be
able to control myself another example
of me not being able to I go I will have
to I I don't want to be rude to someone
in their own house or on their own
compound yeah you know I can't do it and
then of course we get there he's as
Charming as anyone could ever be and I'm
just like you guys we have to get out of
here I cannot be seen with this level of
a republican I'm like we have to go in
my family and it was just this and then
he's showing me his artwork and I have
my sunglasses on because I had taken
like a really strong edible and he's
like going up I'm following up the
stairs and he's like look at this
painting look at this painting and I'm
like and he goes can you take your
sunglasses off and I'm like I'm under
the influence of cannabis and I cannot
take them off I told him yeah I had to
that's like 10 million cops I know no
well he's not gonna be like he probably
he's trying to be cool so he's like yeah
yeah he knows what's up he's sober so he
had a good time once and then uh I I
take that's what silver means had a good
time you used to be fun and so then he
takes his glasses off like this and I or
I take my glasses off and like look at
his artwork and I was like I didn't know
what to say I'm a Philistine when it
comes to like you know paintings and
just say breaststrokes but yes and I
said I just looked at the picture and
said wow the paint is so thick
okay and that was like okay I gotta get
the [__] out of here now that is it I
know I mean it was ridiculous I was like
great and then we're driving home my
brother goes
my brother's like God he goes oh stuff
like this only happens when you're
around I'm like obviously Roy what do
you think you're gonna Bush's house
that's fair but I mean I also
that's a big high profile example but
things like that are always happening
and I'm you know that's what I write
books about and do my stand up about and
everything is about myself deprecating
lifestyle you're so right I I just said
to Val the other night I was like I
forgot that there's like it's almost
essential to keep some self-deprecation
in in your in your stand-up some I think
it more than some yeah I hear you and I
just forgot it was one of the spices
it's something I've been doing at 20
years now and it's just kind of like
it's too much of a foregone conclusion
that you should do well and it becomes
almost like a monster then you're like
wait we got into this because I wore
like button-down rayon shirts I was
always blushing and I had wet hands you
know what I mean like that's why I I
started it so why are you acting like
something else just because people come
and see you like remember that yeah keep
a tether to it so I guess it's also
different styles of Comedy too not
everybody is self-deprecating you know a
lot of people are observationalists and
then that's about other people's ways
but I yeah I'm very excited I haven't
made cotton balls men don't need cotton
balls is that an impersonation of who
that was Bill Cosby oh copy sorry I'm in
jail now what's the deal with the bars
they're always horizontal makes me look
fat it's just like Bill Cosby
Jewish like a Jewish what's the deal
with clams almost like a black she
speaks Spanish it's never really
explained it's almost like a black
Seinfeld Theo get in here okay Ordinary
People okay I'm getting it now yeah I'm
good I got it consider it gotten
let's unpack that George W a little bit
just a little bit because you are
um
a coastal Elite liberal I'm just kidding
but you're not a republican no I'm not
and I'm also a coastal Elite liberal but
I did expect you to laugh at that and
you just were like yes well that's what
I am yeah that's what I've always wanted
to become it was a coastal Elite liberal
could I also just say I think I told you
this where I saw you you did that video
for the rndc and it killed no did it at
a show that nobody thought that show I
heard bad reviews so funny we were
supposed to do this event together yes
and well we've unpacked it a little bit
on the show it just went sideways it was
just not an easy game I was in DC and
you sent a video and I was gonna fly
back and then like the day before I was
looking at my calendar just like I was
looking at it today to see that I was
kind of to guess where you lived yes and
I was looking at my calendar and I was
like there's no way this makes no
[__] sense I'm flying back to LA to
do a charity event like to come back to
DC tomorrow right so then I bagged on it
and I did so an event for the
environment and flying across the
country two times well that was my
opening joke well you'll never believe
how I got here
perfect but the joke that you did do in
the video so that again I should have
been more self-deprecating at that night
a lot of nights I look back and I'm like
oh I should have just gone more low
status and you kind of wanted that in
this very Charming way oh thank you yeah
it was it was incredibly right on tone
for you not being there which is a
pretty good skill big compliment yeah to
prophetically go like I think I know
it'll be so it's all these bigwigs and
then it's a it's a thing for Julia
Louis-Dreyfus and it's a thing for the
environment and you made this perfect
joke about
um because of course none of us ever fly
private and then you went
and it I was like it was right there two
things I was like one right material for
the event because that that's a much
safer way to score and also you know
play to the audience well thank you yeah
you did you did a great job let's unpack
the coastal Elite okay liberal I'm just
I'm with you
um I had my issues with W Bush's as well
like like we all like a lot of liberals
did and when you meet people I know it's
so annoying I'm just interested in the
separation between the office and the
man because he
I'm going to load you with this and then
I'm going to stop talking but it's like
he is sort of playing a character in the
same way that a judge is playing a
character I know he's still making
choices but he's almost like making the
choices through the fill or he's
supposed to make the choices through the
filter of his party and his and his
cabinet and all that sort of stuff and
and what it means to be the president so
then when you meet him and he's just a
guy eating a ham sandwich it's almost
not like meeting the president does that
make any sense yeah I can hear what I
see what you're saying I mean also I
mean there's a million ways to justify
that reaction like for you know I don't
think George W Bush was necessarily in
charge of that much when he was running
things it feels like Dick Cheney was
yeah maybe we should see it together
again because I think that it he I mean
that's a justif that's me justifying it
but I also like it's over and done you
know it's my attitude like when I was
there I mean I resisted going there but
then I was like you know in my
intellectual brain instead of my
emotional one I was like what like it
was before the 20 2020 election so my
whole thing was like if I'm here I have
to say something to him about Donald
Trump like I have to tell him that he
needs to be outspoken because it was at
a time where no big Republicans would
speak out against him and I was like I
can make I'm gonna at least try yeah
um but you didn't do it you just ate two
Edibles uh well I did it later a hard
cut the pain is so I didn't do it no I
didn't do it I emailed I emailed one of
the girls after and asked them to do it
with to ask him to make a public
statement and they said you know that
wasn't gonna happen why are you friends
with Barbara I don't know I've just met
her over the years Jenna and Barbara uh
like at different events and I just love
that I like twins
as a Coors Light commercial just like
twins football grilling I like twin
girls yeah yes
and they have to be the daughters of a
former president yes and then it's like
it's like a denting commercial for me
although twins are fun I think twins are
fascinating I'm very curious about twins
well they're I was talking about the
girl that had stand-up body twins is
also like celebrity body because I when
I walk around with the scar Brothers
they literally get recognized twice as
often as any of us because there's two
of them you see Randy you're like is
that the guy from Monterey then you see
Jason you're like ah what's the guy from
Ohio there's two chances yeah two
chances it sounded like a bit not a bit
these are fresh yeah I'm at the grill
fresh for you okay I didn't even see the
girls so I'm glad that you pointed it
out
I love it and I need it
um well I don't know what to talk about
now
okay well do you want to talk about no I
got it okay what did you have no I was
going to say climate change we could I
mean that's not fun let's talk about
something fun you want to hear my bit
about climate change sure I go are the
the scientists that are predicting that
the world's gonna end in like 10 years
do they still floss it never works it
never works no I can see why
she hates it yeah he kept it real
because floss is like no what would you
say it would be like
do they live in Barbados do they eat
entiments I would have to think about
that one you'd have to work on it yeah
yeah the floss is the one to be okay
here's my question what does it feel
like for you to not be real and the
times that you have to suppress oh I
don't like that feeling I don't like
being fake at all I don't like uh where
did you get this where did you get this
confidence
that has that that's not confident I
think it is is it being like the you
insisting on being yourself at any cost
awesome it sounds like something Winston
Churchill I don't like ass kissing like
the second one I'd rather die than Chris
I don't want anyone kissing my ass
either like I don't like that like it's
in an obsequious way like I like when
people are respectful but I don't like
when somebody's like blowing smoke up my
ass I have no tolerance for that and I
don't we cut in front of the line to
take a table at a restaurant yeah yeah
I'll do that and hello
not a line I mean I'll call ahead and
say you know get a reservation that's
not the situation here's the situation
you walk in and they go yeah Miss
Handler yeah yeah yeah and they remove
moshe's drink from the table especially
them I'd cut them twice those two
for sure
and they know what I'm talking about
what if it's a person that's a fan cut
in front of their table Yeah you walk
into the restaurant and this person is
like oh so nice to meet you Chelsea it
is our 15th wedding anniversary no no no
no and then they go not if it's not okay
I wouldn't do that so as soon as they're
human it's like naming a lobster they
have an anniversary well you can't boil
a lobster you name this is what we're
saying well I don't know I've never had
a lobster for long enough to like even
find it yeah I'm not going to house a
lobster
good use of house thank you but as soon
as you name a lobster you can't boil
boil Larry I would I would boil it you
would yeah who cares really yeah if I
named a lobster I would have no problem
eating that Lobster really naming it
going this is a delicious Larry yeah and
then shooting it with like a handgun to
kill it is that how you kill Lobster
yeah it's better than boiling it a lot
it seems like the quickest way to get a
lobster is to shoot it shoot it you
could shoot in that middle part where
all the green Gunk is nobody likes that
I think that's their [__] the [__]
is in the middle which is
your middle [__] the green stuff is
isn't that their should you be
you know I I believe it is so wherever
that that's their intestine then and
then their [__] I guess the shooting
is not in the middle of their body it's
on the end well you know maybe it's like
us like my poop is like around here too
I think that's where it works its way
yeah because when you open a lobster
it's centralized it's like a centrifuge
hot ones and you eat a centrifuge yeah
that's a centrifuge Ascent s-c-e-n-t
because it's their poop a centrifuge I
saw you on hot ones and you like me will
eat the cartilage off a bone and my mom
will rip the legs off a lobster and suck
them oh because she's a first generation
Lithuania you don't throw that oh
that's nice what are you
[Music]
Russian polish and German oh yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah nothing too exciting
happening over here it's a snooze well
he's going to mention that you got
really sad when you found out that thing
on the ancestor show but when it's not
that kind of show no no do you want to
talk about the Holocaust if we're not
going to talk about climate change yeah
that's a good shift okay I mean that's a
little bit more upbeat kind of change
Elaine let's not talk about the
Holocaust you we're leaving climate
change you passed the Holocaust in the
lane and now we're going into another
Lane okay which was what it feels like
to be fake you hate being fake okay
right yes and you ate having your ass
kicked kissed kissed I don't want to get
my ass kicked either can I just agree
with you that the times when I was in a
club like in New York or or anywhere
really and they were really mean to me
like I have a memory of them being very
mean to me like the owners or the
Bookers or the other Comics yeah yeah
the one that comes to mind is this place
in Milwaukee I just Googled it I wanted
to see if it was still like still
holding on to it like whatever really
what happened just like they used to put
a gun on the table when they pay you
they scared us like it was just like a
scary situation yeah a gun yeah they
were they like they prided themselves to
be like mafiosos oh well that's not yeah
and I you'll hate I think you'll hate
this I can't forecast climate change or
how you'll feel but I said to him
because I was so ass kissy because I was
a year into comedy he had a great Club I
was like such a free Club thanks for
having me and he was like it's because
when we welcome to the table we go you
ready to laugh like he like took credit
for it that he's scared right right and
it was like it's not just the perfect
Acoustics and the location it's you
anyway
why did I bring that up I don't know if
I go back to a club like that and then
they're nice to me it actually makes me
feel really sad it's not angry there's
something about phoniness or like why
would human beings suddenly be nice
because you've been on TV can you relate
to that feeling or is that not why you
don't like having your ass kissed or
kicked I mean and I like when people
like have accolades or they're like fans
of mine and they're sweet about it I
just don't want like there's a way to
say I'm a big fan of yours and or I like
you you know without kissing ass kissing
ass is fake and it's always it's just
like uh you can smell it from a mile
away that's why I Like Comics who I
guess you know try and play a persona
it's like they you have to really be
that person to some degree you know what
I mean and pick your persona wisely yeah
connected or adjacent to the one you're
already working with facts I see a lot
of comics get stuck in their Persona we
say that I said whenever stand-up comedy
I'm it's one of my favorite pieces of
advice I picked up along the way it's
like pick one that's close to you
because you don't want to get stuck
until like what if what if you change or
don't pick a Persona yeah there's it's
even better but if you're gonna pick a
Persona then make it relatable to who
you are or close to 70 what is the 70 of
your personality that shows up the most
consistently that's your persona yeah
right like I believe Jerry Seinfeld
really is like Theo oh sorry
I wasn't
left yeah I
like Dad same I wanted him and he
probably wanted to be my dad too and
Krasinski the camera one I just I just
was like this is the life these guys
have the life I wanted to be part of the
Huxtable family yeah sure like I just
when they would sing songs it was just
so idyllic I know and all the shows with
their swinging doors for the kitchen
like I've never been in anyone's house
who really has a swinging door I did a
multicam and I had a swinging door and
it made me emotional I know they have to
yeah it was probably the set from the
neighborhood when I moved to LA when I
was 19 years old I was like thought I
was moving on to the set of Three's
Company I was like come and knock on my
door you know like I was I was ready to
live on the bike path and just roller
skate everywhere wait you could be like
the Susan yeah yeah and people say I
look like John Ritter so I'm just saying
oh you do look like John Ritter and I
have a Thigh Master so there we go it's
like basically done we just have to get
Mr Roper and Mr Furley actually I'm
better I'm more into Mr Roper than Mr
Furley who was your preference I'm
trying to remember
I think I like the the old guy they're
both old Roper is older oh Roper yeah Mr
and Mrs Roper Mr yeah yeah I didn't and
a flaming homosexual yeah I I was more
about the couple that was so annoyed
because I think I related to them even
as a child I was like I would hate these
swinging signals I don't want them
living together like I related because I
grew up religious oh yeah you mentioned
PD asks what's the name of the podcast
it's not is he called Petey no oh God I
was like that's embarrassing you made it
weird what is it called you made it
weird oh is the name of the podcast oh
oh tell me about Ayahuasca in a way that
you didn't tell Stephen Colbert because
that I mean I need more I'm just kidding
um I think why did you do it well I was
filming a special for Netflix I do a lot
more things on camera than I would
probably do if I wasn't being filmed
yeah because you wanted a novel idea
well it's like it's cool to experience
Cher like it's experiential so I like
that aspect and I like to be filmed
doing things for the first time so that
it's real react actions can I ask why
what is the mission statement behind
that to take people through something
like you're doing it to show and
demonstrate to people what it's like as
a novice who has never done something
before or even interviewing questions
and like putting yourself in situations
that other people you might like maybe
aren't going to have the guts to do I
like to do that because and and then
it's it's it's good to like be brave in
that sense to like go the TV helps you
be brave right yeah yeah yeah I feel the
same way I wouldn't care so much about
Ayahuasca doing it but I was curious
enough and I know that I have a good
handle on drugs like nothing's gonna
overtake me you know what I mean like
even Ayahuasca no it wasn't going to I'm
strong and I knew that I mean drugs I
have like I've done every drug there is
and like you know it was very my
understanding it's like a channel
changer like you go somewhere else yeah
you do definitely but isn't that
wouldn't you call that overtaking no it
didn't because at any moment I could
have stepped out of it like I was in
control of the experience it didn't take
over where I was like like you know I
was like at any moment I could have
stepped up walked downstairs and and
finish which is exactly what I did when
I got my message I was very in control
of my other girlfriend and my other guy
friend that came with me had a really
different experience the Bush twins and
then yeah Laura and Barbara Bush we all
did Ayahuasca and Peru together and we
faced time with George W
ow
for covet so we were Skyping of course
and uh yeah so it was a I think you're I
think drug experiences all have to be
you know they're all up here people get
really scared to do drugs and if you're
really scared then you shouldn't do them
but you're saying you have to remember
there's no real danger yeah you have
other than a psychic break I mean you
could have yeah you could if you're
depressive it could trigger something
yeah and you have any history of
depression that's our eyes too we should
also mention yeah you can die on
Ayahuasca if you if you're on
antidepressant so luckily I don't have
any of those issues so you that's
actually okay that it's almost teasing
the spiritual thing it's like you're
remind remembering I would say that the
spiritual journey is remembering that
you're not in any danger
here as well that's sort of one of the
tenants I think for me yeah I would say
that too but I would also say that um
specific to Ayahuasca it's a commentary
on an aspect of your life it's not your
whole life like it was very specific was
mine was my relationship with one of my
sisters my older sister and it was all
about she her and me and that was it
there was no other thing there and it
was just very focused on that and then
it changed our relationship forever
because I realized I was being such a
[__] really yeah and then I was just
like you must have been a real [__] of
Ayahuasca if Mother Ayahuasca was like
of all the things we could intervene
yeah you would be closer to your sister
it was basically be nicer to yourself
not the secrets of the universe it was
like yeah
wrong they're like listen step one try
not to be such a [__] I'm like what what
do you mean before we get anywhere else
yes yeah yeah so did it show you moments
with your sister like were you yeah it
was a phantasmagoria of like this like
of all these moments just like an iPod
Shuffle of us on the beach and my
parents had the summer house in Martha's
Vineyard and we would just be on our
kayaks and she and I would run and chase
each other up and down the beach we were
even wearing the same bathing suits we
grew up wearing like when I was like
four like Ayahuasca got it right you
like the dog was there a dog I hadn't
thought about in 25 years I was like oh
my God there's Muttley there's and then
like all the Care all the scenes were
real and it was just like it just kept
flipping flipping through all the scenes
in our life and there was like a voice
in my head saying you're not the same as
her you're different you have to love
her she doesn't want the things you want
you're not right and she's not right
she's your sister you have to love her
and it was bad everybody wants the same
thing overwhelming like an overwhelming
amount of emotion yeah where you're just
crying dying but you're happy and you're
loving and you just feel so loving I
honestly think the most important drug
for everyone to do if you can do drugs
is Molly because that changes the game
too people really loving tap into
something that they that you don't
that's not that easily excess not as
easily accessible without it yes like
couples do therapy on Molly that's
actually kind of a synchronicity for me
I'll take even a low grade synchronicity
because when I did Molly on our it was
either a honeymoon or we went back to
where we honeymooned we want one of the
trips there and I took it and I had a
very mild experience meaning I wasn't
like
we had done it both times we were there
and the first time I remember jumping in
the water and it felt like swimming in
olive oil you know what I mean I was
like the water was like and I could hold
my breath in really long time it was
incredible like I swam all the way to
the bottom of the ocean I was like I
know it wasn't that deep but I was like
I know there's a lot of pressure on my
head but I can't feel it and I was like
I felt like I could have stayed down
there for an hour like I I was
completely fearless and my sober
observing mind was like no you need to
go up and I was like okay relax but
that's my attitude the whole attitude
towards all of my fear was like like
this weird like kind of Woody all these
scandalized comedians but like a Woody
Allen you're gonna die you know it's
like shut up like everything's fine but
you do have to keep an eye on that but
the the takeaway I got from that
second trip which wasn't a big dose was
people don't have to be like me which
was sort of like your Ayahuasca like
your sister doesn't have to be like you
what makes you happy doesn't make your
sister yeah yeah yeah judgment meaning
yeah exactly what what people don't have
to be like me is saying stop judging
people yeah yeah like who's to say
You're The Benchmark you're the market
right exactly you'll stand in the center
of the circle and and call everyone else
out for not being like you but when you
really hear that it's like it's the most
simple thing but it's like the biggest
Game Changer in the world like one of
the biggest game changers yeah yeah as
long as you're listening right if you
can hear it yeah but I think in those
under those circumstances I mean drugs
are just phenomenal in the way that they
can heal people and the way that they
can build your awareness and perspective
because it's not natural to be always
thinking about the way other people are
perceiving things you know we're so far
up our own [__] for so many years
until we actually decide oh I want to
dig even further up my [__] and go to
therapy because that's basically the
irony of of of like becoming less
self-absorbed is
that you have to talk about yourself for
several hours a week to unpack it all
well the weight of the darkness the way
the light is through the darkness with
yourself you're like oh [__] you again
yeah but it's worth it it's not pretty
or you know it's not but like there is a
level of you know confidence and there's
a level of Integrity that come along
with doing that kind of work on yourself
to find out why you're a [__] [__]
when you're an [__] why are you
reactive why are you competitive or
jealous or digital or why are you not
happy for your friend you know you have
to pick yourself apart and be honest
with yourself and say this is where I'm
coming up short and this is how I'm
going to improve myself and you have to
be serious about
getting bad information about yourself
people are going to you're you're paying
someone to tell you what's wrong with
you and you know you don't have to frame
it like that but that's what it is
you're like an outside opinion yeah
you're like I'm gonna need a second
opinion on this yeah that's really
interesting Val and I were just talking
about how drugs can uh even though that
doesn't matter I'm not gonna Clear My
Throat there the idea that sometimes you
don't know what you feel you know I mean
you're so conditioned to be a certain
way or to think a certain way meaning
you don't even know what you don't know
meaning you've been watching movies and
we watched The Cosby Show and that told
us what a family should be and we watch
advertising and we listen to music and
we're part of this culture so much so
that you know we're fish that don't know
we're in water sometimes you take a a
substance like a holy substance that
reminds you like you're none of those
things which leads me to my next
question meaning those things were added
to you but there's something more
fundamental that you are and I would use
capital A or are truly underneath and
those
like other lenses were added on top but
you need to get in touch with what you
are when you took Ayahuasca you said
it's all in your mind
was
look science can't find memories like if
I look at your mind I can't find you you
know what I mean I can't extract it I
can't download it and there's different
theories on that we're not we're both
out of our our depth here we just have
to watch an episode of Black Mirror they
do it like every other episode yeah
exactly why don't we have it if they
have the technology it clearly does it's
like it's not fictional right like
somebody over there figured it out let's
go and they're trying to prime it into
the into the first one was they had an
episode where they like get someone's
brain chip so then then they jog their
memory and so everything they did is
recorded in their memory so if you were
involved in a crime like every little
thing you know is recorded right and I
was like God I hope I'm dead by the time
this becomes a reality well that's
interesting but then you are the person
that just told me a story about
Ayahuasca showing you a memory with your
sister and you remember the bathing
suits and a dog you hadn't thought about
so like where is that and the not being
able either of us to get the answer
having an ex experience like Ayahuasca
did it did it enter your mind that it
was possible that your essence
traveled or joined with a higher
Consciousness like not just exploring
the four corners of your brain but
something a little bit more substantial
happened yeah I felt definitely like I
was above and out of my body yeah felt
like that for sure right but when I
wanted to be grounded and I wanted to
feel my body like okay can you feel your
legs can you feel your arms I would be
able to yeah and then if I let myself
kind of slip away I would be over my
body and kind of looking down at this
view that was the scenes that were
playing out from my childhood right so
I've had a lot of spiritual experiences
you know because you I I I mean you can
do acid you can do mushrooms and all of
those things have healing benefits as
well when you're you know you're doing
it with a professional or you're micro
dosing it for you know depression and or
the corn concert anxiety exactly but
um
but uh
I've had a lot of spiritual experiences
doing collectively like just like you
know not not not trying to have a
spiritual experience but doing trying to
have fun with friends and taking a bunch
of mushrooms and then having like a real
oh you know like that's one of my
favorite yeah things about it is that
there's I've been told there's an
expression in India that God uh we're so
materialistic that God came to us as a
material does that make sense like the
60s and and now we're in the third wave
of psychedelics it's like there's a
yearning for our true selves to connect
with us yeah and if it's in this culture
or this time or whatever it sort of
meets you where you are and we are in a
place where it's like you know there's a
lot of this going on there's a lot of
eating there's a lot of pleasure seeking
there's and isn't it funny you know
ancient Greece was the same way the
ancient rituals it's like there's all
this decadence and you do this stuff and
but it it you end up having an ego death
which isn't something that you would
normally sign up for right right I don't
know if I'm yeah I feel like ego death
is the goal but how could you possibly
be involved in like everyday life and
also exist like that well it's temporary
or yeah yeah temporary but ideally like
if you wanted to become someone like
Eckhart Tolle or who just seems to have
an ego yeah
yeah Deepak Chopra seems to have an ego
but Eckhart Tolle seems like he's on
another field of Consciousness
completely are you down with the toe
yeah I'm into him me too I think he
no I'm not that into him but I mean I I
haven't seen him live is what I'm saying
I Gotta See Him Live but he was the
first person who spoke about
Consciousness in a way that made me
understand it yeah because I you know
you hear all of it it's all the same but
everyone says it slightly differently
and for him for me I listened to a bunch
of stuff of his and I was like okay I
think and I listened to it over and over
again I'm like okay I gotta understand
this me too it's funny well when you
were talking about your Ayahuasca
experience one of the things that you
were doing was remembering to be the
witness of it like if that was your
advice I know you weren't giving advice
but when we're freaking out
Even in our Waking Life if we want to
call Ayahuasca kind of like a dream I
know it's not a dream but it's
hallucination but in our Waking Life
this hallucination we're having right
now if I'm feeling anxiety there's a
great value to going like I'm seeing the
anxiety like I witnessed the anxiety
meaning
is this is a ramdas quote but is the
part of you that's noticing the anxiety
is it anxious or is the part of you
that's noticing the depression depressed
and I know there are people that are in
real deep depressions this isn't going
to work like I understand meaning I
don't want to be glib and be like this
works every single time but for me with
low level stuff if I'm going like I'm
afraid is the part of me that's noticing
the fear of frayed and the answer is no
and then then the job and really the job
isn't even Enlightenment or or salvation
or conversion it's really just happiness
is to retreat I'm so out here I get too
worried about what Chelsea thinks about
like all the stuff that you don't worry
about as much as me which is beautiful
what do people think about me how's it
going or whatever just [__] stop and
go back into the Observer which is what
Eckhart teaches right is that there's
not also none of this matters right like
nothing matters like to be stressed is a
futile exercise where are you causing
stuff offering to yourself there is no
point you can't say that to someone
who's high anxiety and gets stressed out
all the time they're like that's easy
for you to say you're right I'm not an
anxious person but I just want to say
like all of the feelings that you're
describing it's not that I feel this
confident all the time I'm constantly
having the same conversation like those
those are not your real feelings anytime
insecurity bubbles up I'm like no no I'm
not listening to you I've got this over
here that's my little girl self that is
scared and insecure and is acting based
on past events that have happened that
were you know uh it's your pain buddy
it's like these things you still carry
yeah and as an adult it's your job to
get better at dismissing that voice and
going no no I belong here that's right
let me you walk in my you know be
grounded because grounded is really the
place you know is especially in this
business because it's such a roller
coaster you know I've been not grounded
I know what that feels like and it's
like a [__] balloon that's about to
pop you know you mean when you're at
certain peaks in your career well when
you're not ground when you're not like
experiencing it Moment by moment when
you're moving so fast that you missed
the parade like you're missing it I've
done that I've done the I've done it the
good way and I've done it that way and
obviously I prefer this where you can
actually do what you're doing yeah and
be present for everything and actually
pay attention to everyone not be
dismissed dismissive not to be entitled
and not to be arrogant
beautiful beautiful beautiful
a big Eckhart Tolle thing that changed
my life I was just touring this past
weekend and I do I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this I'm not just going on a
thing but like I catch myself looking
forward to the show being done even
though I love doing the show doing
stand-ups yes there's a great relief
when it's done and I still maintain that
that is true because even though we've
been doing it a long time there's always
a what if something goofy goes wrong
what if I whatever it just isn't working
I can't find it whatever it is so
there's always a relief but Eckhart has
this thing he's like stop doing things
as a means to an end and do them in and
of themselves and his example and I
think about every time I do the dishes
or wash my hands try to it's like just
wash your hands or just go up the stairs
or that's what one two thing two things
at once right yeah but like
that witnessing presence that is life
itself Capital life itself is with you
in all of these things and I think what
Eckhart is doing is maintaining a
connection to that even while you're
going up the stairs I won't bring you
into this but I like a lot of people get
too glossed and like I'll be happy when
I'm winning I'll be happy when I'm
eating I'll be happy when I'm having sex
or whatever it might be whatever your
thing is sometimes I'll be like oh when
my daughter goes to sleep I'll be
watching the office with my wife that'll
be happy and that those are now
those moments when you can notice you're
being insane that like it is it it is
insane to assume there's a future for
you to feel better and it's so much
better I think to try and settle and
like we're saying to retreat into some
some access to
joy joy now a joy for no reason yeah you
know what I mean but yeah and I think
it's easy though like the simple joy is
the best kind like to be able to
cultivate because then you can be joyful
in like you know dark moments or in
tough spots yeah because we all have
that right like everyone goes through
tough spots sometimes like your career
is easy sometimes it's hard
relationships easy hard all family all
of it and it's like how do you operate
when things are hard yes you got to be
really in touch with yourself can I
please love because like
is that Marilyn Monroe thing where it's
like if you if you can't handle me at my
worst you don't deserve me at my best I
I a spin-off of that is like everybody's
happy when everything's going well like
the point of life is to figure out to
find something that's non-circumstantial
or I would even say trans-rational
meaning Beyond like I can explain to you
why I'm happy I'm going to be talking
about this for a while poor Katie and
but I I won't belabor it but we got a
flat tire coming home from the airport
yesterday or two days ago and it's
really I can't do it right away flat
tire
pull over major road so annoying it
wasn't like I was yeah exactly I wasn't
like going off-road major road leading
to the 101 flat tire we had to pull over
it's raining it's it's Sunday night it's
six o'clock nothing's open like you
can't do it uh and it's a [__] Tesla
so you can't you can't there's no spare
that's like a neon thing I know
I'm just kidding suck at him so he well
more on that but we're we're in the car
and Val is a mindfulness teacher and it
was very helpful when I was worked up
she was calm and then she got a little
worked up and I was coming and then we
both like found a cruising altitude to
just be like
we're sitting in chairs you know what I
mean yeah we're sitting in chairs I know
that sounds so silly but like what is
the issue I know you're on hold with a
tow truck I know we really want to get
home before Leela goes to bed but really
right now it's another Eckhart toy thing
sorry you brought him up but I'm just
going to gush it if you don't mind he's
like you haven't been waiting in line at
the airport for three hours you're
waiting in line at the airport right now
and I use that one all the time stop
like stop torturing yourself with the
memory like I've been on hold with this
tow truck for 45 minutes no you haven't
you're on hold with the tow truck right
now yeah we took an Uber home it's also
just when you see yourself lose your
cool it's it's so not a hot look
facts so it's better not to do that you
know
and I die
um Charles Chels
when we come leave that hanging that's a
question as an open-ended question we're
gonna go to the the little mid-roll ad
but when we come back I'd love to talk a
little bit about you you talked about
when you're not grounded because that's
very interesting to me and I'll I'll
commiserate with you that there are
times when you start to lose your
footing so we'll get into that and I
actually believe it or not prepared some
questions it just says nipples here oh
did you want me to take out my nipples
again oh my god well come back after the
mid-roll for a blurred nipple we have to
blur out I I can't do a whole interview
without taking my top off
so stick around for that we'll be right
back
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought To Us by our friends
at Sundays food for dogs the only dog
food that is healthy easy to store it's
basically like having a box of cereal in
your pantry easy to store meaning you
don't have to have like we tried this
one thing where it was like little
containers all up in our fridge like 70
of our refrigerator was dog food which
was ridiculous this is Sunday's food for
dogs it's like having a box of cereal
easy to store and for real like a 90s
dog food commercial when I break out the
yellow box of Sundays Brody loses his
mind it is absolutely Bar None his
favorite dog food and it's my favorite
dog food too because it's unbelievably
easy and it's so nice to see him happy
and devouring it Sundays is air dried
dog food made from a short list of human
grade ingredients Sundays was co-found
co-founded excuse me by Dr Tori a
practice interesting veterinarian
Sunday's uses 90 percent meat 10
vegetables and zero percent synthetic
nutrients besides USDA beef and all
natural chicken you'll find digestive
AIDS like pumpkin and ginger plus
disease fighting antioxidants dog
parents report noticeable Health
improvements I can attest to that in
their pups including softer fur fresher
breath better poops let's be honest
that's that's number one on my list you
get way better poops and more energy
Brody absolutely scurries on the ground
and slides like he's on Ice to get this
food when it comes out unlike other
fresh dog food Sundaes is zero prep zero
mess and zero stress like I said it
doesn't overtake your fridge it goes
right in the Shelf it's shelf stable
which makes it easy to feed your pup top
quality food every order ships right to
your door so you never have to worry
about running out of dog food again
which honestly was a big problem before
we subscribed it's so easy now it's a
no-brainer Sundays cost 40 percent less
than other Healthy dog food brands
because Sundays doesn't waste money
shipping Frozen packages which is also
just a huge waste instead they spend on
their materials sourcing the best
all-natural ingredients for your pup so
we worked at a special deal for our dog
loving listeners weirdos get 35 off your
first order for Sundays Go to
sundays4dogs.com weird or use code weird
at checkout that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash weird upgrade your pup to Sundays
and feel good about the food you feed
your dog
also brought To Us by our friend at
Rocket money do you know how much your
subscriptions cost each month most
Americans think they spend about 80
bucks a month on subscriptions when the
actual cost is closer to 200 bucks 200th
if you don't know exactly how much
you're spending every month you need
rocket money rocket money formerly known
as true bill is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions they forgot about I'm
certainly one of them like that
streaming service you bought to just
watch that one show hello Nexium or that
free trial you never even used rocket
money will quickly and easily identify
identify your subscription for you so
you can stop paying for the ones you
don't want simply find the subscription
you don't want and press cancel rocket
money will cancel it for you no more
long hold times with customer service or
tedious emailing back and forth where
they're just trying to trick you to stay
on Rocket money makes canceling
subscriptions as easy as a click of a
button over three million people have
used rocket money saving the average
person listen to this up to 720 a year
it's incredible it couldn't be easier I
was deeply unaware air deeply unaware of
how many subscriptions I had just
running in the background and auto
renewing and just costing more and more
money and Rocket money makes it so easy
to get rid of all that and save you get
that cash back in your pocket all with
the click of a button so stop throwing
your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
weird that's rocketmoney.com weird one
last time rocketmoney.com word
last but not least I don't know if you
guys know this but it was raining uh in
Northern and well I'm in Southern
California but in Southern California it
was raining I mean the northern part of
Southern California that was that's why
in Southern California it was raining
for about I don't know nine years we
have a river in town now there's a river
it's been so muddy and so wet not to
mention we love to hike all of this is
to say we needed to upgrade our shoe
game and let me tell you vessi shoes are
an absolute Game Changer why is the
vessi storm burst the best shoe I have
ever worn in the winter time and
obviously here right now in the wet wet
mud of California well they have all the
features of a rubber winter boot built
into a sneaker
are you are you nuts a hundred percent
waterproof not water resistant water
proof and warm yet lighter and more
comfortable than boots also a lot easier
to put on than boots I mean there have
been a lot of times I wanted to go on a
hike and I'm just like I can't I can't
with the boots These are basically
slip-on they have a lugged lugged lugged
that's supposed to be rugged they have a
rugged rubber outsole that gives you
extra grip and wet conditions and added
lining inside for extra warmth in the
cold and they slip on and off it's quick
and easy to get outside they are made
from dimetex what is dimetex it's a
super soft knit material that keeps your
feet warm in the cold but cool in the
winter months and doesn't feel like it
should be waterproof doesn't have that
like claustrophobic absolutely nothing
happening in their feeling but it is
it's absolutely it feels great and it
keeps the water out super comfortable I
also think they look great some
something about the diamond text looks
like a designer pattern so I get a lot
of compliments when I wear them Plus
they're awesome they they don't slip on
rocks they keep you warm they keep you
dry and they slip on and off like
sneakers it's an absolute game changer
for walking the dog going on Hikes and
just keeping my feet dry nothing worse
than wet socks nothing worse than wet
toes guys keep it keep it dry downstairs
Messier My go-to Shoes by my door check
them out in the link vesi.com weird for
a pair of your Bessie shoes all you have
to do is Click vessey.com weird and use
promo code weird for 15 off your entire
order thank you again vesi use promo
code weird for 15 off your entire order
it's the only shoes you need because of
how versatile they are show your support
of the show bestie has saved my feet
from those soggy soggy socks all right
everybody get back into it
we're back
what's up what's happening
um not when we're not grounded that was
interesting to me you sort of teased I
do feel like there's a million ways to
go with you and they're all interesting
and they're all funny just another a
nice a nice compliment I do want to talk
about the times in your life when you
kind of lost your footing when you
didn't know how many times tell me like
was it your first break was that a
tricky time oh no it was probably like
[Music]
um
probably when I was leaving Chelsea
Lately I just was so sick of everybody
and everything and working in my voice I
was just so like was the tank empty I
just was pissed I was pissed that anyone
let me work that hard like I had written
four books gone on like four major tours
while I was filming Chelsea Lately in
the seven years that I was there and
like no one stopped me and like I would
I was like why isn't someone looking out
for me like I'm I'm and then of course
that's going to result in me not wanting
to work you know I was just like [__]
everybody is that what you did did you
take it I just quit yeah oh I didn't
know you could I quit my e-show I just
quit on I think on Howard Stern so that
wasn't the best either like I used to do
[__] like that without thinking like I
just assumed since I wanted to quit that
everybody else knew it because I thought
it you know so all these people who
thought they were just going to be on
the show forever and ever were like well
[__] our ride is over you know not that
they didn't contribute but like it was
it was a car ride I would talk to Conan
about he produced this is the backdrop
for my old talk show so he this is
something that he told me was like he
felt this obligation to not quit because
the quote I think was something like
because there's 300 people that work
yeah well you get over that yeah because
you can't you can't do that you know I
stayed up for two years because of that
reason it's like staying for the kids
exactly and then eventually you get to a
place where you're like I don't want to
do that so I was pretty out of control
at that point in my life like I just was
off the rails I had a really I was in a
bad relationship
um like you know an unhealthy
relationship and I was just tired
exhausted and and aggravated yeah you
know and so then that was like bad
self-care did you figure out I'm
assuming yes that no one is looking out
for you in that way like no one yeah
like in this business no one is gonna
say even we talk about balance all the
time on the show and it turns out if
people are on the payroll typically
nobody's gonna go Chelsea I don't know
if you should write that fourth book but
even and no one's going to tell you
anything to like no one's going to tell
me what to do even my sisters aren't
going to be like you're working too much
or like they think I can handle it
because I'm not sitting there you know
what I mean like no one it's not
anyone's job to know except for you is
that it oh like you're supposed to know
when you're working too hard and you
shouldn't be like when you're young and
you start to get successful you think
you have to do everything that comes
your way and it's not until you're older
that you realize okay well that was a
great foundational like ground that I
lay but now I get to decide how often
I'm going to work and when I'm going to
work and if it's going to be worth my
energy and time I'm not trying to
impress my publicist or my agent by
being a team player it's like your life
I'm deciding what I do all the time we
go good life when like you're gonna wake
up like so many of us are going to wake
up and be like what was all that for
yeah people are gonna have certain
amounts of money they won't even be able
to spend it it'll be like Brewsters
Millions like you can't you're now
you're 90 and and it just was all work
it was pushing around Rock up a hill for
somebody else and and that doesn't just
apply to show business jerks that's
everybody it's like at what point do you
start going like I think we learned that
during the pandemic like a lot of people
in life I wasn't alive during the
pandemic yeah I know you were
cryogenically frozen I remember that was
with Walt Disney for those three years
did something happen
you didn't miss much actually it doesn't
sound like it it was kind of nice
because it's like pretty lame it wasn't
nice it was but there was a Daniel Tosh
joke where he goes I don't want to die I
want all of us to die it was about like
whenever the world was going to end yeah
um and I felt that about stand up I was
like I don't want to take a break from
stand up I want all of us to take
breakfast oh yeah yeah
I enjoyed wow are you okay oh God no I
think I just kinked my neck damn it am I
allowed to say that in here yeah great
you said [__] earlier I know I was
joking I'm not asking for provision to
say God damn it
we're too far to high five but no no
we're good foot five is that it's
happened before is that a thing oh
leaving me hanging on the foot five oh
sorry
[Laughter]
you'll get seven cases of Magic Mike
that's all you can get all right well
that's good to know are you okay is
there anything I can do for you can I
just had to stretch mine now do you want
to Advil PM take the edge off to go to
sleep no no stay awake but at PM usually
usually indicates it's a night time I
take them in the morning just to kind of
round out the edges of the day
here's my question for you I'm proud of
it let's see how it goes I could say
that before any question are you a
person that people just assume is okay
in general not just in your work and
then people are kind of like like have
you had to learn how to say because you
are a strong person um
hey that hurt my feelings or hey I'm not
okay like I have to imagine your sisters
your partners the people that work for
you might have had to learn Chelsea is
not
oh yeah always ready to break through a
wall like the Kool-Aid sure absolutely
and you that is a process how did you
figure out I mean I know now and to ask
for help but like everyone knows if I
get stressed out I don't really I mean
I'm pretty straightforward so it's not
like I'm ever pretending like if I'm
stressed I'll say I'm stressed out I'm
dealing with this issue but uh yeah so
you did say like should I be doing four
bucks and people were like no no not
during that time now I'm at a point
where I can do that but yeah no I think
everyone was just thinking it was going
great so it was going great and then it
wasn't you know everything works until
it doesn't until you're like out of gas
and you're just like oh my God all I
wanted to do was like leave the country
and not speak publicly for a year like I
just didn't want to talk I was sick of
myself that's why like like Chappelle's
thing for example like there's a part of
me that was like yeah I get it yeah when
you're completely out of you just said
it basically you were like I wanted to
get out of here and did you after you
quit forgive me for not knowing but did
you basically don't worry about that I
took a year off oh I got a Netflix deal
Netflix I signed a deal to do a talk
show first they I said I don't want to
do a talk show right away I need a year
off and they said sure you can take a
year off but I said I'd like to do a
documentary series with four
documentaries and one of them was the
Ayahuasca episode and so I and and they
said sure do that and then I'll start my
talk show the next year and then I did
the talk show for two years after that
and then that was it and then that was
not that was not a good experience
creatively for me I didn't want it I
didn't want to be working but I you know
made a deal because it was that kick in
was it the first day the camera that
wasn't in a good I was that that's when
I I was not grounded I was not grounded
I was not secure in my decision making I
was very it was just a very uh difficult
time can I just offer uh almost in my
experience nothing worse than to have
the appearance of your dreams coming
true and being miserable like like
feeling sort of worn out yeah well it
was more that I just was so unsure of
myself there were so many circumstances
around it that just weren't a lot like
it wasn't easy it wasn't easy what was
shaking your confidence I don't know I
think I guess maybe leaving e and you
know that was a big shift everyone
couldn't believe that I would walk away
from something like that and then you
know you go from working all the time to
being on vacation for a year and you
have that whole basket of like thinking
and you just said this the things that
make you successful also make it
impossible for you to enjoy your success
often like it's hard for you to go what
was it like the year off like you oh no
it was amazing but it was like I just
then I just became disassociated from my
work I was like oh well I'm just not
gonna work anymore and you're like well
that's not a good plan you've got to
work like I needed to find the balance
of because I really do like to travel
the world and I do like my time off I
didn't like being I felt like I had a
boyfriend I couldn't get off of you know
like that wouldn't get away from me with
that show I was like I had to be home in
La like 46 weeks a year and I just was
like pissed I'm like I want to go
[__] I want to go somewhere for three
months I want to go buy a house in Spain
I did you know I did the things I wanted
to do and then you kind of come back
around plus Trump had been elected that
was very upsetting to me this is right
before you were frozen yeah that was
when I had to become Frozen and then
yeah they reduced me to an embryo
oh you're a little froze and then they
regrew you yeah that's great yeah it's
amazing what they can do
and they can download your brain so you
okay I it's funny I was wrong a couple
times like trying to guess what you were
feeling because obviously I was
projecting how I sometimes feel yeah I
think that's what you were doing yeah
for sure yeah no I absolutely was but
with a good intent hopefully to see you
light up and be like yes but it was
interesting you were more like
I'd like this is this is keeping me in
LA
yeah I felt tied down I like to be free
to a bad boyfriend is what you said yeah
tie down to yeah in more ways than one
like literally I had a bad boyfriend and
also the show it felt like a bad
boyfriend right there was like a bunch
of bad boyfriends and I just wanted to
be free like and I wanted to go and like
spread my wings in a sense well that's
really interesting because I I love your
I love your cram
oh thank you I had to [__] remember
what Graham is short for I was like
Golden Graham something like where did I
do it you love golden brown I [__]
who [__] doesn't love Golden Grahams
I'm a free Dahmer I know he probably
loves it too let's be honest it was
great it's like he's pretty open to
putting anything in his mouth that is
true that is true Golden Grahams is The
Unsung Cinnamon Toast Crunch and we all
[__] know it I don't know it's better
than Cinnamon Toast Crunch okay fire I I
will say that golden crabs is better
than Cinnamon Toast Crunch Cinnamon
Toast Crunch is like a B plus and golden
grams is an a look at my face yeah
Golden Grahams is the name a cereal
better than Golden Grahams Reese
's nope
Honey Nut Cheerios maybe not a classic
like yeah but that's that's not Superior
to say something
honey that Cheerios with almond milk is
better well everything is better with
almond milk facts that's funny on hot
ones you called almond milk [__] milk
well that was before I started drinking
it I always become a hypocrite whatever
I was against drugs too at one time
really yeah when I was like 14 I was
like I can't believe you guys are
smoking weed to all my friends in high
school I was like that's so
irresponsible you guys are such idiots
kind of thing yeah no I just thought it
was like you know I don't know I just
had to have an opinion about it even
though I was based in nothing in my punk
rock band we had a song uh called fry
the fish p-h-r-y fry The Fish the band
fish about how you're an idiot if you
sit in a lawn chair and take
psychedelics
and look at me now take a look at
Logan exactly that's what that song's
about actually
I I think I know that okay
I know you're waiting for a bigger
response than that yeah it was and I
loved that you were giving it did you
finish the song no I I love the realness
I think I think I worry that you think
I'm putting it on but every time you
just don't waver in your commitment to
yourself
and that's where I was going Golden
Grahams your Gram I know lots of men and
women frankly I'm a man but I know a lot
and I'm a woman it's like Anchorman I'm
a man and you're a woman uh sorry weird
quote that's okay sorry we have another
mineral I'm just kidding um people are
inspired like you've you've taken
um and this is not the interviewer I'm
like why didn't you have kids or get
married you've taken those Life Choices
or you know into this celebration of
what you're saying like you want to be
free and I really enjoy those posts as a
married person with a baby I I I'm still
meaning but there are a lot of women I
know that are on that same path that
take a lot of inspiration from it oh
well I'm so glad because you know I um I
talk about it a lot my last and my most
recent special Revolution on Netflix
because it's like it's not an under it's
a very underrepresented group of people
like people need to be like so funny so
many like married women will be like
okay we get it we get it you don't like
children you don't like marriage I'm
like I don't care if you get it I'm not
here for you I'm here for these girls
right that are being asked and berated
every single time about when they're
gonna have a baby when they're gonna get
married it's so [__] annoying to be a
woman and having to answer that question
if you date somebody if you're if you're
not dating somebody why can't you date
someone why aren't you with someone like
something's wrong with you it's like
hello what about some agency I've had
some of the best times of My Life by
myself yes stop it we need to advertise
that there's another path to choose
especially if you're not 150 behind
becoming a parent I'm all for it if you
are but a lot of people don't think it
through and we're putting people in the
world like I would like you to take that
more seriously it's a consequence that
walks around and buys bread yeah and I
have of your weird choice and I'm aware
also of my bandwidth and that is being
like I crush it as an ant I I can be
available to my eight nieces and nephews
all the time and that's as much
bandwidth as I have for children super
fun and yeah because I don't have any
kids to deal with of myself I'm like
Rolexes yeah but I give them edibles
way before they're supposed to do them
okay so do you really yeah oh they're
teenagers well they're yeah they're in
college most of them yeah okay there's
only one little one yeah they must be
thrilled they love it they love me I
mean you do cameos I don't mean the app
I mean like are you popping in a dorm
room and blowing Minds I mean they must
be so funny no I'm not doing that no no
I'm not I'm not yeah that's a little bit
that's a little too much it's too much
for me yeah
I did go to my one nephew's dorm and I
think that was the last dorm I went to
the first one that went to college my
brother and I went down there once and
then uh yeah I haven't been back since
to any dorms
it didn't cause a scene or did it no we
didn't see anybody we just went to see
his dorm room it wasn't like that yeah I
understand yeah no well people are into
it and then and I I'm all about the
freedom and I wasn't going to ask you
about I I grew up in New England and it
always struck me that the The Witches
the the women that were accused which is
like calling them Witches Witches of
Salem The Witches of Salem yeah Salem
town which is now Danvers oh they
changed fun fact well Salem is Salem
Village is Danvers and Salem where Salem
is nothing of historical import happened
there that's just a fun snooty thing to
say if you're from New England oh okay a
lot of people don't know that so you can
be a real piece of [__] okay but
everything happened in Danvers it's
called Danvers now anyway
um those were single women that were
usually I think attractive and unmarried
and so what I'm saying is even in 1692 I
think we're still kind of living with
some of that
what are these what are these women
doing withholding their eggs from men or
I'm wondering what your take on why it
was so hard culturally
well I mean we're like baby makers you
know it's like a societal construct that
was created for population but we're
overpopulated too many people right we
can't absorb this we're just we just
exceeded eight billion people in this
world and 9 billion is the max China
luckily's population is the one country
that's gone down because of their one
baby rule you know that they had for so
many years I think I don't know do they
still have that rule uh that you have to
have like one anyway they're really
their population is has diminished for
the first time in like 40 years or
something yeah so
um but it's it's just pretty I I just
think it's all [__] like anyone who
tells you what to do or you're expected
to do and I just think all of that's
[__] like you have to really
understand what your purpose is and what
you're good at and then try and just
like whatever you can do to like spread
Good Vibes it's funny here sitting on
this couch
in our lives I feel like that's kind of
common it's like nobody can tell you
what to do but I actually think what
you're saying is super super important
and can't be repeated enough because
there's a lot of people I'm from Boston
so I had family members that I swear
when they were in Boston they were still
under this like spell there was like a
spell that you have to do certain things
I swear I've seen gay people pretend to
be straight I've seen people that didn't
want to God how tragic I have kids you
imagine having to pretend also listen
like let's not not we're just straight
people thinking they had to get married
or whatever right but I mean yes it's
all [__] up like to have to pretend
that you're something that you aren't is
terrifying and horrifying and also I'm a
white straight cisgender CIS female you
know what I mean like so it's not like I
have came up across against all these
challenges you know I'm pretty confident
because my life hasn't been that
difficult right you had a lot more
advantages than me yeah but yes I mean I
probably I probably did with these boobs
I probably did have more advantages than
you I mean it's not like I
accomplishing my goals it wasn't that
hard I mean I've been to been through
traumatic situation
yes you systematic oppression yes yes
um have you ever seen a ghost you seem
like a lady that's seen a ghost
I don't think I've seen a ghost no I I
felt I felt a ghost before tell me I
mean I don't have a great story about
ghosts because again really not my
problem you know what I mean yeah sure
like I'm not going to get scared about a
ghost but I had a boyfriend who has he
goes he had a haunted house he was
haunted and his house was haunted and
there was definitely a ghost in his
house I mean that I felt 100 that that
was a ghost really just a Vibe yeah like
door slamming cold breezes footsteps
like this is a good ghost story yeah
yeah I just stayed away from that part
of the house it was a part of the house
yeah a little bit the ghost Wing yeah
kind of and why didn't he move because
it was like it was his summer house and
he summer ghost yeah summer ghost he was
summering there
he was actually from Nigeria and he
summered and yeah in the cape again yeah
Cape Cod yeah Cape Cod I we had a
cottage in Cape Cod and we thought it
was haunted too but we were kids
everything's haunted yeah I mean I
believe things are probably haunted yeah
what about you lingering around UFO yeah
probably I mean I I haven't seen one
myself but yeah I could believe all of
that here's one I bet I don't I I've
been wrong so many times I couldn't be
more happy
um you seem like somebody who maybe has
talked to some pretty high-end psychics
oh yeah definitely ever have your mind
blown oh yeah I had an asteroid this as
a steering astrologist who reads your
chart the time of birth and your date of
birth you don't give them your real name
his name is Jade saluna on Instagram so
he doesn't give us his real name he no
he doesn't oh that was funny
um I had to tell you and uh you did
because it slipped I didn't get it
um but so he won't tell us his name I
I've I've been to him and he [__]
rocked my world he gave me specific
dates of things that were gonna happen
and they happened and like oh yeah just
it was incredible
without even nothing you don't know I
did a fake name and my date of birth and
time of birth and then yeah from Chelsea
exactly I always make all of my own
appointments
um so uh so that's incredible and then I
have yeah there's a psychic that I talk
to go into the future though or was it
just yeah it was all about what's gonna
happen this year the next year the next
year after that it was like an overview
of my chart and like he described the
last five years of my life and and in
the most app description that was true
everything he said was he's like you're
just coming out of this cycle and this
happened this happened this happened
this happened and everything had
happened and I was like holy [__] and
then at the end of the phone call he's
like who are you and I'm like Chelsea
Handler and he's like oh my God I'm
coming to one of your shows I have
tickets to your show and I was like
you're wrong about that I'm like guess
who's gonna be my [__] friend you did
you meet him yeah yeah I met him he's
come to my show and now we're friends so
and then I have this other woman that I
talk to and she's been right on too so I
mean I I've been to therapy and I'd
rather just talk to us like an
astrologist at this point I'm like it's
always good they always have great
things and it all happens the way I I
feel like when you're um open to those
things yeah
more things become come to you like when
you're really close kind of opening a
door or something yes when you're really
close-minded and you think all of that
is [__] then it is yeah and you
don't notice the little things because
there's kind of like little mysticism
and a lot of different things and Brandi
Carlile talked about it in her book she
there was a sentence that said something
like never underestimate mysticism like
coincidence and and when things feel
aligned so I'll take a low-grade
synchronicity remember earlier yes I was
like oh that's the same thing I'll take
it right Valen I say count it meaning
like what's the harm it's it's nice and
the longer we've been together and the
more I don't we get into that flow the
synchronicity is getting nuts like like
what was it
so I I ordered socks on Amazon this
isn't like a phone listening to me thing
and then Leela my daughter and I were
watching some cartoon and they it was
like Elmo was opening a gift
so I ordered the socks then we go
downstairs and turn on the TV it's mid
episode he opens the box and it was
Daniel Tiger it doesn't matter but he's
like what's in the box and I'm like I
don't know I'm [__] a ball or
something dumb [__] it was socks like it
was pairs of socks I know that doesn't
they never sound that great in the
retelling but in the feeling you're like
just these little breadcrumbs of like oh
yeah I kind of feel in a flow or
whatever and those psychic things can
feel that way yeah yeah so I'm open to
all sorts of [__] yeah that like
that I like it and me too I think it's
it's like the attitude of magic we've
also sat on the show it's like you can
be that for other people yeah you know
what I mean like if I'm
bad example I pay for your meal like in
that moment I'm the universe winking at
you you know what I mean like you become
an agent of those types of feelings for
other people and then they're real in
the same way that I make Santa Claus
real to my daughter I eat the cookies
the joke was Santa Israel I pee out of
his dick like he's me do you understand
does that make sense yeah like Santa
isn't real but I'm Santa so Santa is
real yeah also not it's both yeah I get
it have you ever almost died
probably I mean
I mean yeah I've been in some close
situations I don't think I've almost die
but I mean
no reptiles nobody
I've been in some Riptides no black
diamonds Riptides oh you've been pulled
away from the shore uh yes yeah I have
been scary scary who saved you Judah I
saved myself oh nice your inner Jude Law
I was in Hawaii on the North Shore in
Oahu with my sister and we got in the
water and we shouldn't have gotten the
water and we got swept out and then the
lifeguards were all on the beach
screaming at us were to come in and she
and I were trying to help each other in
but we grew up on Martha's Vineyard
which has in our opinion had pretty big
waves and we thought we knew what we
were doing and then uh we were trying to
help each other and then finally I was
like everyone on their own
swam
and then we're like for coming out I
mean we were wrecked and uh and it was
so funny Shawn was like thanks a lot I
was like listen We're not gonna get in
together holding on to each other that's
true probably true but I was definitely
going to save myself at that point this
is why Ayahuasca was like we got to talk
to this lady yeah exactly that's why
she's been holding that Grudge for
[__] ever what a great answer yeah
although most people drown if someone
tries to save yeah and we both survived
so that was a victory that's what I'm
saying yeah a lot of times if if a
lifeguard is trying to save someone
who's drowning and they're pulling them
under the move is to to hold them
underwater until they pass out don't
anybody try that but that's what I've
been told
heard that one because they'll kill you
they'll kill you yeah I think you're
supposed to also hold them they're
supposed to have them swim on your arms
so you have one arm out and you swim the
other arm and that way they're holding
onto your arm instead of your body when
you save somebody in the water that's
the last I heard okay real tap mine was
just from like 19. yours is to commit a
homicide so that's [__] up
okay here we're at the spirit this was
such a day off for me I gotta say what a
what a thrill I'm looking at my notes
just to make sure I didn't miss anything
but I absolutely didn't because you're a
delight nipples by the way was just you
said in an interview why can boys show
their nipples and girls and we don't
have to talk about it well yeah it's
back to the moment yeah that's just not
fair Angel [__] thing yeah you know I
mean Madonna the Madonna yeah yeah sex
worker as Sarah Silverman said uh
Silverman is how she likes to pronounce
her last name said that women can
provide life with our breasts and now
and but we're still getting punished for
it you know they just passed a law in
Missouri that you can't in the state
legislation that they can't wear uh
women can't wear short sleeves they have
to wear suits really yeah they're not
allowed to show any skin that's in the
state of Missouri
so I'm headed straight to DC after this
I'm heading straight to Missouri I love
some slave
nothing gets me that's how we reverse it
by the way is if I'm like nothing gets
me hornier than sleeve like just start
that sorry yeah and be like sleep in
Missouri yeah or Sleepless in Missouri
lives in Missouri yeah starting Tom
Hanks that's a good one we can do that
okay do it all right I feel like between
the two of us
you're going to make that happen before
I will well thanks for having me this is
just great we didn't talk about God that
was the last thing we sort of touched on
it and I'm really glad that you feel
good and I feel great too but you you we
already teased it so we don't have to go
on and on but I I'm curious here's
here's our way in fresh do you think
death is the end
I mean I think that energy you know
transforms into something else I don't
think I mean again there's a precedent
for that I've been trying to do this on
stage it's like you die you go into
nothing but don't forget that the
Universe erupted out of nothing so like
don't be afraid of nothing because at
the end except when it's the beginning
does that make sense well no not really
but I think that well then let me say it
three more times I think that yeah I
think it's whatever you believe and it's
nice to have an open mind so that just
in case you know I think there's
something mystical there too that I
can't put my finger on but I definitely
have a very um close relationship with
my mother who's dead more so than when
she was alive like I know when she's on
me or around me and I feel her so I know
that's that on you like her Energy's on
me like I could see if I could feel her
like holding your arms
near me no she's never she's like you
like this but it's an energetic thing
and the more tapped in I got to it the
more I believe it so I believe in that
but I mean who [__] knows whatever
yeah I'm gonna hope that that we
transform I don't want to come back
again I don't want to I'm not into
reincarnation like God this is a really
good life I'd rather not come back and
not have this kind of Life you'd have to
go to and have to go to war or something
you know what I mean well Dan naderman
had a great bit about that where he's
like I don't want to be reincarnated
what are the chances I'll be born in
America again yeah and I was like that's
it's very funny I mean it's sort of what
you're saying yeah so you're open not
too worried about it you know Eckhart
figured it out here is that something I
feel like it's important to respect
every the idea of all of it being a
possibility and to respect the fact that
you're not here for yourself by yourself
to be really conscientious and mindful
of others to really be able to be like
kind of a beacon of light to a lot of
people especially when people are in
like arrears or having a bad time like I
really like to show up for people when
they need it so that they feel like seen
and like loved and I feel like when you
focus on doing those things and your
intention is really coming from a loving
place then the whole [__] world just
opens up to you then you can be great at
your stand-up you can be great at your
TV show you can be great at hosting
whatever the whatever it is you're into
when you're acting in love and like
kindness like everything kind of comes
together in an easier way life becomes
easier yeah staying in touch with that
that kinship that shared love that yeah
completely agree uh and this isn't the
last thing I'm going to say but that's
what you're doing here today it's so
nice that you've shown up to this thanks
yeah you're not um phoning it in this is
the last I feel like you're phoning it
though but I'm very good at putting it
in yeah meaning me phoning it in is is
better than most people really preparing
yeah oh if I was really at it I'd be
speaking in Latin okay
I don't know how it could be better my
riff was I'd speak in Latin because I
think I'm so good that would be the only
way to improve do you speak Latin
pluribus
um
yeah there we are okay I just hate
pluribus because everyone knows yeah
Unum understood okay
here's
the last question
um
that everybody gets can you think of a
time in your life that you laughed
really really really really really
really really really really hard
and here's because it's a pressure
question but it's not it actually isn't
it doesn't have to be a great story
I have an answer okay great
um you're the first person to stop me we
went we came home from the Limelight we
used to go to the Limelight in New York
City I lived in New Jersey we would take
acid and we would drive back from the
Limelight and I was always the one who
had to drive through the tunnel because
I was the most together out of my
friends and we were driving back it was
like 4 30 in the morning or and we had
our SATs and my friend and I sat on lsts
yes there you go and we went to the
school and I was like we have to take
our SATs on acid like this is [__] up
and we went in and I put my name down at
that time SATs were like 1600 right like
so you got like 200 points for writing
your name and I wrote my name and my
girlfriend was across for me we had sat
outside the school because we got home
at like 5 30 in the morning but we
couldn't go home because we were so
[__] up but we had to take our SATs
and it wasn't until like 7 30 8 o'clock
that it started so we sat outside
Livingston high school and just were
smoking joint after joint after joint
trying to come down from the acid and we
go in and we take the test I try to take
the test and I write my name down and
just
well that's it you know like I this
isn't gonna work I can't take a test and
I put my pencil down and just looked at
my friend and at you know in the same
moment we both just lost it like what
are we doing like no we're not gonna
take this test right now but we both
went in there like we can do this no
problem you know these weed joints will
help us we got we got kicked out of
class and we were laughing so hard that
I was holding my vagina as she was
kicking me out of the class like the
Proctor because it was like a Saturday
morning and they were kicking us out and
like you can't be here you know you
girls are [__] up or whatever they
were going to call our parents but we
were like no no no we're not we're fine
we're fine but as the girl we were being
removed from the class like I remember
holding my vagina over my jeans and just
urine coming into my hands and I was
like oh my God oh my God I'm going to
urinate in front of everyone on the
morning of the SATs because I'm on acid
I was like you can and I remember saying
you you cannot pee your pants and so my
friend I was like if you laugh again
it's coming out right and I just looked
at my friend I go french fries french
fries from McDonald's there's nothing
funny about that that's what I need to
think about and that's what I just from
that moment on anytime I get the giggles
and I can't control myself which is a
great [__] feeling but I have to like
if you're in church you know the
circumstances are high I always just
think McDonald's french fries there's
nothing funny about it
and that's how I stop laughing I mean
they're delicious but they're not funny
there's something funny about the way
they spring out it sort of looks like
the original French fry the best french
fry there is McDonald's I mean and
Wendy's they use their own special
potato that's super long that's why
they're so long oh really yeah hmm yeah
they also don't go bad oh okay so oh
they don't are you one of those rich
people that still [__] with McDonald's
no okay no no I don't [__] with
McDonald's but I will [__] with Wendy's
on the way home really yeah I'll get
some a six piece chicken nugget really I
like those
isn't that like a pressed meat isn't it
like 30 000 chickens pressed I mean it's
disgusting
yeah that's pretty bad
well
this is awkward because everyone has to
go to wendys.com weird for ten percent
I'm gonna be there I mean when this is
live I wanna I mean when this podcast
comes out I'm just gonna be at the
Wendy's all day that day for a meet and
greet yeah me-a-t yeah I love a meet and
greet
I love meet and greets Chelsea I want to
give you every compliment you don't have
to your heartfelt you're fun day off and
you're also I just want to say like
you're incredibly High processing like
you like you like you should get your
brain scanners oh high processing what
does that mean like processed meat yeah
thank you you're total nugs and I mean
that is like such a compliment because
you're so high processed thank you just
brilliant thank you for doing this thank
you we have the guest say keep it crispy
it doesn't mean anything it's not a
trick but would you say keep it crispy
say goodbye keep it crispy
bye bye
[Music]